how important is it for a writer to know
their own personal story not the story
they're writing but who they are their
own life's journey
um conflict in their if your terms for a
writer I would think it's not that
important no no that's not I know it
might be surprising to hear that but me
it's not that important the thing you
should be aware of is human dynamics you
know psychology emotions character
relationships that you should be
well-versed in now lucky is the writer
who has had an amazing life experience
and had all those experiences that he
can write about that makes it easier but
it's not necessary if you're a highly
curious person I mean you know you could
be a great writer who's had a very
mediocre life you know I mean I'm not
I'm not a believer of the Hemingway
thing about you know if you want to
write about adventure you got a you got
a go and be adventurous and stuff I mean
there may be some truth to it but I
think it really depends on your mind and
your curiosity you know and I think we
can all find you know it's all about
your imagination if you have if you're
highly imaginative you can you can write
about anything whether you experience it
or not you know if you write science
fiction you know George Lucas didn't
didn't experience going on a ship in
order to be able to write about it right
or James Cameron you know do you think
he do you think all the stuff of a
Pandora and Avatar that he experienced
and in his own life no it's all
imagination right so that's what you
need you need you need to know you need
to have high imagination obviously but
then you need to know be well-versed in
character relationships so yes if you've
had experience recurrency relationships
that's great and character conflicts but
if you haven't you can always learn it
and if you're highly curious you know I
mean I've a psychology degree so if I
wasn't a writer I would be a
psychologist because that's what
fascinates me I'm fascinated by human
interactions even psychology and
especially the reason why people do what
they do which is what characters doing
stories so really you know that works
for me but my life story as much as it
was it I considered very unique and
different
most people's life stories I don't have
the desire to write about it so it
doesn't affect me at all in that in that
sense so then someone shouldn't totally
oh just for yeah me rephrase it I think
I understand what you're saying yeah
this is usually and it's different for I
think it may be might be difference it
might be different for you know because
that's usually what you're taught you
know you have to use your kind of like
sense memory and that kind of thing but
for writers and but again I don't think
this a yes or a no for me I don't think
it's important like it doesn't have to
be for others it might be and and I'm
aware that if that if it did happen to
you then and you want to write about it
then of course that makes it easier
because it happens to you'll be a lot
more realistic but you know well you
talked about today that that one you
gave your class that many people noted
that they wanted to write their own
story yeah which I think it's about
writing that yeah a lot people well
that's because they think that their
life stories are interesting every I
think right everybody thinks their life
story I mean everything's there to hear
of their own story and there's a little
truth to it but I gotta say I mean if
I'm talking from experience and from
hearing people's life stories that they
want to write as movies I would say
about 90% of them are not that
interesting
they just the the writers themselves
think it's interesting I don't think it
is interesting in an audience's don't
think it's interesting so they got to
learn that they that's why feedback
comes in if the feedback is okay well
you know I mean I always bring out
Hitchcock's quote about you know drama
is real life with all the boring parts
cut out so a lot of people feel that
just because they've had a few
interesting experiences may be unique
that it warns them to making a movie out
of it they may be right but a lot of
times they're not well I found that some
people who have had incredibly
interesting albeit hard lives actually
don't think they're that interesting and
in the reverse is actually alright yeah
people that have had oh yes and this
person in the and it's not actually that
exciting but then I've talked to several
people it's true that their lives have
been very difficult and challenging and
they don't really see it as anything
interesting right and I'm always
encouraging that's word feed exact
that's what feedback comes in and
they're like it goes you know because if
they hear everybody telling you then
eventually they'll believe it right so
get feedback interesting
you